an abandoned building in the suburbs of
bangkok but look closely and there are
signs of recent life
since kovitz struck homelessness has
been a growing problem in bangkok with
unemployment rising and the economy
entering a prolonged downturn
rongsak has been living here for some
time scraping a living selling empty
bottles and other rubbish
even his narrow margins have now been
cut in half
this is a very difficult time for me i'm
collecting less scrap to sell and the
price of recycling material has gone
down i used to make around 12 dollars a
day but now i'm lucky to make half of
that
and this is an increasingly common site
in thailand people queuing for daily
handouts of food
the government promised that economic
recovery was on its way but since the
end of thailand's covert isolation
things only seem to be getting worse
the whole covid situation is not really
improving but the government isn't
facing the truth
more people lost their jobs more people
are ending up on the street and becoming
homeless people who have no choice when
they don't have money to pay for their
essentials and have no safety net and no
welfare
despite the fact that vaccinated
visitors can now return
few are actually doing so
that's bad news because tourism is such
an important employer and income
generator
here on bangkok celebrated khao san road
there are still relatively few
backpackers and despite lifting
quarantine conditions it's expected that
visitor levels next year will still be
well below those before covered
the government already facing criticism
for its slow vaccine rollout is putting
on a brave face
it's predicted moderate growth and a
swift recovery to pre-covert economic
levels
but the indicators seem to be pointing
in the other direction
household debt is rising oil price is
rising inflation is getting more of a
concern and interest rates are about to
rise i think
lots of uncertainties in 2022.
bangkok's famous nightlife will remain
shuttered for the rest of the year
even when the bars and clubs are allowed
to reopen in january 2022
many will remain closed for good
right now there isn't much to celebrate
tony chang al jazeera bangkok